THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE.
CALDERON CARRILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible]
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMO OWN.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVASRODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE.
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
AMBER IS.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
AS PART OF THE ASSEMBLY SAAB
SERVICE OBSERVANCE OF YOM
HASHOAH HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN.
RABBI JULIE WEISS A CONGREGATION
OR IN ME IN CALABASAS CALIFORNIA.
RABBI WEISS.
OVERWHELMED BY THE HUNDREDS NO
THOUSANDS OF SHOES LINING THE
WALLS OF WHAT IS LEFT OF THE
AUSCHWITZ CONCENTRATION CAMP.
THEIR X. I TURNED TO SERRA
HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR.
ON OUR TRIP.
I SAID SERRA HOW CAN YOU KEEP
TOURING THIS AWFUL PLACE FILLED
WITH MOMENTS OF TERROR.
AND FEAR.
AND I WILL NEVER FORGET WHEN SHE
LOOKED UP AT ME.
STANDING AT NEXT TO THE BARRACK
SHE SLEPT IN FOR MONTHS WHILE
STARVED.
AND EXHAUSTED [inaudible]
JULIA HONEY.
THOSE SHOES YOU STOP ALL THE
VICTIMS.
WELL REMEMBER THAT MY SHOES ARE
THERE [inaudible]
TO REMEMBER.
SUCH A SIMPLE REQUEST YET SO
DIFFICULT FOR US TO ACHIEVE.
I FEAR THAT WE'VE BECOME NUMB TO
THE HORRORS OF THE HOLOCAUST.
MODERN LIFE HAS FORCED US TO
CONFRONT VIOLENCE AND TERROR ON
A GLOBAL SCALE.
EVEN REGION INTO OUR BELOVED
STATE THE ANTI SEMITIC ACT OF
VIOLENCE THE JUST HAPPENED A FEW
DAYS AGO.
WE WITNESSED THE DEMONIZATION OF
THE OTHER ON A NEARLY DAILY
BASIS.
CIVIL DISCOURSE AND COMPROMISED
HAVE ALL BUT DISAPPEARED FROM
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LIFE.
BUT TODAY'S CEREMONY IN THIS
DISTINGUISHED ASSEMBLY GIVES ME
HOPE.
HOPE THAT THERE ARE THOSE AMONG
OUR POLITICAL LEADERSHIP WHO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE CAN KNOW THAT
WE MUST REMEMBER THE LESSONS OF
THE HOLOCAUST.
THAT TREATING MY NEIGHBOR AS
THYSELF IS V. UNIVERSAL THEME OF
ALL THE WORLD'S RELIGIONS NOT
JUST LIMITED TO JEWS CHRISTIANS
AND MUSLIMS AND CERTAINLY NOT
JUST LIMITED. TO THE JEWS
CHRISTIANS AND MUSLIMS WHO
PRACTICE THEIR BELIEFS EXACTLY
AS IDEA.
AS MY COLLEAGUE RABBI SHARON
BROWN'S TEACHES.
HOPE IS NOT NINETEENTH AND HOPE
IS NOT AN OPIATE.
HOW MAY BE THE SINGLE GREATEST
ACT OF DEFIANCE AGAINST THE
POLITICS OF PESSIMISM AND
AGAINST A CULTURE OF DESPAIR?
AND SO I INVITE YOU TO JOIN ME
IN A PRAYER OF DEFIANCE.
HOLY ONE OF BLESSING MAY YOU
INSTILL WITHIN US THE ABILITY TO
FIGHT AGAINST OUR PESSIMISM AND
DESPAIR.
EVEN AS WE REMEMBER. TO SEE THE
SHOES AND EVEN WHEN WE SEE THEM.
TO RECOGNIZE THAT IS WITHIN EACH
OF US TO ENSURE THAT THE HORRORS
OF THE HOLOCAUST.
ARE NEVER REPEATED.
GIVE STRENGTH TO THE SURVIVORS
AMONG US TODAY.
THAT THEY MAY CONTINUE TO SERVE
AS REMINDERS OF THE WORK BEFORE
US FOR YEARS TO COME.
HELP US TO FIND HOPE AND LET
THAT.
GUY THE HANDS OF LOOK THOSE WHO
LEAD THIS GREAT STATE THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO BE A LIGHT.
UNTO THE NATIONS.
AND TO THIS NATION.
CAN YOU HEAR ROCKS OWN MAY THIS
BE GOD'S WELL.
ON THAT.
THANK YOU RABBI.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY APRIL TENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN BE SIMPLY MET AT
SEVEN AM ON A WILL IS THIRD ROW
CALDERON MOVES AND MR OBERNOLTE
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES ARE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAN FOR
ILLNESS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN NAY.
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
GABRIEL BAUER-KAHAN QUIRK EGGMAN
AND FRAZIER TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
GUESTS WILL BE SEATED AT MEMBERS
DESKS AND AT THE ROSTRUM FOR THE
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE CEREMONY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT.
FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER CAM TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
MEMBER TODAY DURING THE
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE ARE
CEREMONY AND TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE UP
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM ONE
NINETY FIVE A. B. THIRTEEN
NINETEEN BONTA FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX PLEASE WITHDRAW THE
FOLLOWING BILLS IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
ORDER THEM TO THE SECOND READING
FILE.
AS THEY ARE NOT FISCAL AB SEVEN
FORTY SIX WOULD AND A. B..
FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN TO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
US THE ASSEMBLY TODAY WE WILL
BEGIN WITH.
STIR CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR INTERACTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
COLLEAGUES I HOPE YOU WILL JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF OUR STATES HEALERS
WE HAVE FROM MY DISTRICT
STUDENTS FROM UCSF MEDICAL
SCHOOL WHO ARE FROM THE PRIME
PROGRAM.
WHICH IS TRAINING DOCTORS TO
PRACTICE MEDICINE IN OUR STATE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
PLEASE WELCOME THEM TO OUR STATE
CAPITOL THEY ARE UP.
IN THEIR WHITE COATS.
WELCOME.
MISS WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
AM HONORED TO WELCOME RICHMOND
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER DEMOLITION
JOHNSON TO THE ASSEMBLY TODAY --
DOUGLAS IS THE YOUNGEST CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER THE HISTORY OF
RICHMOND HE'S A FOURTH
GENERATION RICHMAN NATIVE. EIGHT
SCHOOL COMMUNITY OUTREACH WORKER
AT RICHMOND HIGH SCHOOL A PROUD
HOWARD UNIVERSITY GRADUATE.
AND SIMPLY PUT ONE OF THE BRIGHT
YOUNG LEADERS IN OUR STATE WHO
IS OUR FUTURE.
NUMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING RICHMOND CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER DOUGLAS JOHNSON.
THANK YOU MISS -- WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR INTRODUCTION?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER I VERY HAPPY TO
INTRODUCE MY YOUNG LEGISLATORS
GROUP THEY ARE RIGHT UP THERE.
HALEY CAME YES SAMANTHA NO BRIAN
WIDE RODRIGUEZ GUS GRASS AND
ZACH.
LOWE G. A. ODD THEY ARE LEARNING
ALL ABOUT HOW THE LEGISLATURE
WORKS AN AWESOME GROUP OF YOUNG
PEOPLE PLEASE.
HELP ME TO WELCOME THEM HERE TO
THE CAPITOL.
WE WILL MOVE TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE -- ASSEMBLY SECOND
READING THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1-161-362-1215
589-153-71010 WITH THE MOMENTS
TWELVE NINETY WITH THE MEMONS
FORTINO FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS FOR
THIRTY FOUR WITH THE MOMENT. FOR
THIRTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
SEVEN TWENTY THREE WITH THE
MOMENT ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN WITH
THE MEMONS FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN
WITH THE MOMENT. TWELVE SEVENTY
FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS FOR
SEVENTY FOUR WITH THE MEMONS.
THIRTEEN TWELVE WITH THE MOMENT
759-126-51820 612-201-48515
SIXTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS FIVE
NINETY WITH THE MOMENT. NINE
ELEVEN WITH THE MEMONS FIVE
FIFTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO AT THE MOMENT
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN WITH THE MEMONS.
SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE WITH THE
MOMENTS ONE TWO THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS NINE AWAIT WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN NINETY EIGHT WITH
THE MOMENT ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS ELEVEN NINETY
SIX AT THE MOMENT. SIXTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WITH THE MOMENT
SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS TWELVE HUNDRED WITH
THE MOMENT THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX AT
THE MOMENT FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
WITH THE MOMENTS NINE OH SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS. EIGHTEEN OH
SEVEN WITH THE MEMONS THIRTEEN
THIRTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS TO
SEVENTY FIVE WITH THE MEMONS
EIGHT NINETY TWO WITH THE MEMONS
TWELVE SEVENTEEN WITH THE MEMONS
FIVE OH EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS
SIX HUNDRED WITH THE MOMENT.
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN WHAT THE
MOMENTS NINE FORTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS TWELVE FORTY EIGHT
WITH THE MOMENTS TWELVE SIXTY
NINE WITH THE MEMONS FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH THE MOMENT
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE WITH THE
MEMONS FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE AT
THE MOMENT. FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR
THE MOMENTS ONE SIXTY WITH THE
MEMONS BY THIRTY FIVE WITH THE
MOMENT SIX SEVENTY THREE AT THE
MOMENT. EIGHTEEN OH FIVE AT THE
MOMENT FOR FIFTY TWO WITH THE
MEMONS THREE FORTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN SIXTY SEVEN WITH
THE MINUTES SIXTEEN FORTY FOUR
WITH THE MOMENT SIXTEEN NINETY
FOUR AT THE MOMENT EIGHT TWENTY
SIX OF THE MOMENT AND SIXTEEN
ELEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MISTER CALDERON. FOR WHAT
PURPOSE THE RICE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX
PLEASE WITHDRAW EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE WEEKS FROM THE
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE IN ORDER
THE BILL TO THE SECOND READING
FILE AS THE BILL IS NO LONGER
FISCAL.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE
.
MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN AB
FIVE NINETY ONE GARCIA THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY ONE BY
SOME MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA AND
ACTUALLY MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICTS.
THIS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
YEAH I THINK YOU AB FIVE NINETY
ONE IS CLEAN UP LANGUAGE FOR A
BILL.
I PREVIOUSLY PASSED ON THE
CENTRAL BASIN CLARIFYING WERE
RESIDENCY MEANS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE.
I FIFTY ONE NO ZERO THIS BILL
PASSES [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION.
THE NEXT FILE ITEM FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETY ONE AB TWO SEVENTY
TWO THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
ACTUALLY PEOPLE'S.
THIS RESEARCH READY
.
WE WILL PASS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINETY ONE AND MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINETY FOUR EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
AS A LEGAL SIX EIGHTY NINE BY
SOMEONE NUMBER MCCARTY AND
ACTUALLY THE MISSILE UTILITY
DISTRICT ACT.
MR MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS
A MEASURE FOR MY UTILITY
DISTRICTS MIGHT IT'S A DISTRICT
BILL THAT ALLOWS -- THIS IS MY
DISTRICT TO DO WHAT THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES.
HAVE THE AUTHORITY DO NOT WHICH
IS RECEIVE NON STOCK EQUITY IN A
COMPASS SEE IN A COMPANY IN
EXCHANGE FOR PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE OUR EXPERTISE.
THIS WILL ALLOW THEM TO THINGS
ONE TO HELP THE RATE PAYERS IN
THE FUTURE AS WELL AS ACHIEVE
OUR AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS.
AGAIN THIS IS ABOUT FAIRNESS AND
EQUITY ALSO HELPS OUR
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS ASK HERE
EITHER THANK YOU.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO
THE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE.
I FIFTY ONE NO ZERO THIS BILL
PASSES.
WE ARE.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETY FIVE AB NINE FORTY FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE NINE FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY AND
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MR MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS
A MEASURE WHICH WILL ALLOW LOCAL
AGENCIES TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF THEIR SURPLUS FUND THAT THEY
MAY AGAIN MAY INVEST.
IN SECURE FINANCIAL INVESTMENTS
CALLED RECIPROCAL THE PROJECTS
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE ONLY
STATE THAT BANS THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY AND THIS WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
TO INCREASE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FOCUS ON LOCAL INVESTMENTS AND
FRANKLY INCREASED COMMUNITY
BANKING ACTIVITIES ASK YOUR EYE
BUT THANK YOU.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THIS BILL
PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
TWO AC ARE
.
SIXTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER
MCCARTY AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
GIRLS ON THE RUN OF GREATER
SACRAMENTO DAY.
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I SEEM TO LOST
MY NOTE HERE BY KNOW ABOUT THIS
MEASURE THIS IS A RESIDENTS
SUPPORT ON GIRLS ON THE RUN.
THE SAYING IS GIRLS ON THE RUN
WHERE THE GIRLS SO MUCH FUN THEY
ARE UP TOP HERE THIS IS A
PROGRAM AT ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS.
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT OF COURSE FOCUSES ON
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY RUNNING BUT
ALSO A LEADERSHIP SELF ESTEEM
CONFIDENCE AND I GREAT PROGRAM
THROUGHOUT OUR GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WANTED.
TO ASK THAT WE SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE AC EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT AND
AFTERWARDS OF COURSE RECOGNIZE
OUR GUESTS IN THE GALLERY.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY WOULD
YOU LIKE THE FIRST ROLE OPEN FOR
COFFERS.
MR MCCARTY IS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHOR
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON A
C. R..
SIXTY EIGHT THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS
UNEASY ARE SIXTY EIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED NO.
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
THREE ACR SEVENTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
RELATIVE TO DISTRACTED DRIVING.
MR FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT ACR SEVENTY
SEVEN PROCLAIMING APRIL IS
DISTRACTED DRIVING AWARENESS
MONTH.
DISTRACTED DRIVING IS AN
ACTIVITY THAT COULD DIVERT A
PERSON'S ATTENTION AWAY FROM
THEIR SURROUNDINGS WHILE
OPERATING A MOTOR VEHICLE.
THESE CAN INCLUDE TEXTING.
TALKING ON A CELL PHONE PERSONAL
GROOMING OR ADJUSTING THE RADIO
JUST TO NAME A FEW.
MEMBERS LET ME GIVE YOU SOME
SAID TO STATISTICS ACCORDING TO
THE NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION. 73% OF
DRIVERS EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY YEARS
OLD ADMIT TO TEXTING WHILE
DRIVING. TO PUT THIS INTO
CONTEXT TO READER TYPE THE
AVERAGE TAX TAKES ABOUT FOUR
POINT SIX SECONDS.
IN JUST THREE SECONDS OF TEXTING
WHILE DRIVING AT SIXTY FIVE
MILES AN HOUR.
A VEHICLE COVERS ONE HUNDRED
YARDS OR THE LENGTH OF A
FOOTBALL FIELD.
BLINDFOLDED.
CAN YOU IMAGINE DRIVING ON A
CROWDED HIGHWAY IN AND TOLD TO
KEEP YOUR EYES CLOSED FOR OVER
FIVE SECONDS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL ISSUED
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHT
THOUSAND CITATIONS FOR EITHER
TEXTING OR TALKING WHILE DRIVING.
IN THE C. H. P. WAS FUNDED TO
FILL THE VACANCIES.
THIS NUMBER WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER.
THE MOST RECENT STATISTICS FROM
THE OFFICE OF TRAFFIC SAFETY
REPORTED ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN DEATHS ON CALIFORNIA ROADS
AS A RESULT OF DISTRACTED
DRIVING.
ON AUGUST TENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
OFFICER CURRENT RHYS WAS
PERFORMING A ROUTINE TRAFFIC
STOP.
ON I EIGHTY IN SOLANO COUNTY.
IN THE BLINK OF AN EYE ANOTHER
VEHICLE ENTERED THE AREA AND
STRUCK BOTH OFFICER GRIS.
AND THE VEHICLE HE HAD STOPPED.
OFFICER GRIS TRAGICALLY WAS
KILLED.
AND THE DRIVERS OF THE CAR THAT
HE ALSO STOP WAS ALSO.
KILLED.
THE DRIVER THE MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE YEARS BACK TO MISTER
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THE DRIVER OF THE CAR THAT
STRUCK THEM WAS ON HIS CELL
PHONE AT THE TIME OF THE
INCIDENT.
MEMBERS I REALIZE THAT WE ARE AT
THE END OF APRIL BUT THE MESSAGE
HERE IS TIMELESS.
AND SHOULD BE HEARD EVERY DAY
[inaudible]
DISTRACTED DRIVING [inaudible]
KILLS.
DISTRACTED DRIVING INJURES AND
PARALYZES DISTRACTED DRIVING
DEVASTATES FAMILIES AND RUINS
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AND FOR WHAT TO ANSWER A CALL OR
TEXT. TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TRACK
TO LISTEN. TO TO REACH DOWN AND
TRY TO PICK UP THE CUP THIS ROLL
AROUND ON THE FLOOR BOARD.
THIS IS DISTRACTED DRIVING A
CONSCIOUS CHOICE TO TAKE YOUR
EYES OFF THE ROAD DO SOMETHING
OTHER THAN PAYING ATTENTION TO
WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING.
PAYING ATTENTION TO THE ROAD.
YOU WOULDN'T WILLINGLY SHUT YOUR
EYES FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF
TIME WHILE DRIVING BUT THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN I LIKE THE FIRST ROLE TO
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
MR LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
GET THANK YOU JUST REAL BRIEFLY
I WOULD ASK THAT -- YOU NOT ONLY
SUPPORT THIS VERY WHERE THE
MEASURE.
BUT DO YOU ACTUALLY.
LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
AND REMIND YOURSELF NOT TO GAUGE
IN THIS PRACTICE.
I CAN TELL YOU I HAVE A TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL.
WORKING A NUMBER OF VERY TRAGIC
CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT I STILL EVEN CATCH MYSELF.
ON OCCASION.
YIELDING TO THIS TEMPTATION I
WOULD ASK THAT ALL OF US.
REALLY SERIOUSLY EVALUATE
OURSELVES ON THIS ISSUE.
AND RECOGNIZE THIS FOR THE REAL
DANGER THAT OPPOSES.
NOT ONLY TO US BUT THOSE WHO WE
WE SHARE THE ROADWAY WITH SO I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR REMINDING
US WITH THIS MEASURE.
AND I HOPE IT LEARN YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY MISTER.
FRAZIER IS ASKING THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE MORAL.
THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS
UNEASY ARE SEVENTY SEVEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THIS RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED NO.
THIS RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MR
FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN MADAM
SPEAKER.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING OUR
FRIENDS IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER WHO ARE HERE TODAY AND
RECOGNITION OF DISTRACTED
DRIVING AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HONORED TO WELCOME THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS IN UNIFORM AND ALSO SUE
WILSON.
AND UNIFORMED.
OF INDIVIDUAL AT THE HEART
HIGHWAY PATROL AS WELL AS OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE.
AND FORMER SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION JACK
O'CONNELL FROM TEEN IMPACT
DRIVING.
AN ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
EDUCATING PEOPLE ON THE DANGERS
OF DISTRACTED DRIVING.
THEIR FUNDED BY THE CHP.
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF TRAFFIC
SAFETY AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THE CALIFORNIA DMV IN THE
NATIONAL SAFETY COUNCIL MONEY
OTHERS.
THESE REPRESENTATIVES DO THE
HARD WORK TO EDUCATE HELP
PREVENT DISTRACTED DRIVING ON
OUR ROADS.
AND I WANT TO PERSONALLY THANK
ALL OF THEM PRETENDING TODAY.
FOR THEIR EFFORTS IN FIGHTING.
DISTRACTED DRIVING.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING ME.
HELP ME WELCOME THEM TO THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS
[inaudible]
MR MCCARTY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUEST INTRODUCTION.
EARLIER WE MENTIONED THE GIRLS
ON THE RUN PROGRAMS BEEN AROUND
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TO HELPING
YOUNG GIRLS PARTICIPATE IN
SPORTS AND LEADERSHIP LIKE.
THIS FUTURE RUNNER RIGHT HERE WE
HAVE THE FOUNDERS UP HERE IN THE
GALLERY THEY'VE BEEN AROUND
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND TO HELP ME.
COUNTLESS YOUNG WOMEN IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL LEARN ABOUT
HEALTHY HEALTHY ACTIVITIES AS
WELL AS LEADERSHIP AND LIFE
SKILLS -- MY TWO YOUNG DAUGHTERS
BARBARA VICTORIA HAVE BEEN
PARTICIPATES FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS AND SO I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
OUR SPECIAL GUEST THE FOUNDERS
OF GIRLS ON THE RUN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WILL.
BEFORE WE MOVE BACK TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE TODAY WITH US
WE HAVE MANY GUESTS INNER
CHAMBER INCLUDING.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE I WANT TO
WELCOME THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM
ATKINS WHO'S ON THE FLOOR WITH
US TODAY AND SENATORS ALLEN.
SENATOR IS ALAN MCGUIRE MORE
LOCK RUBIO WHITE HOUSE SKIN
GLAZER THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND OF COURSE SENATOR STERN AS
WELL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO THE ASSEMBLY OBSERVANCE OF
THE HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY.
I'D ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS FOR THE CEREMONY
.
AGAIN MEMBERS I'D ASK YOU PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS FOR THE
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY CEREMONY.
MR GABRIEL ARE YOU READY TO
PROCEED ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY ONE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY ONE ACR FIFTY FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY.
MR GABRIEL YOU MAY OPEN ON A C.
R..
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS 2% ACR.
FIFTY FOUR IN HONOR OF HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY.
TODAY WE TEMPORARILY SET ASIDE
OUR USUAL OUR USUAL LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS TO RECALL THE HORRORS
OF THE HOLOCAUST. TO HONOR THE
MEMORY OF ITS VICTIMS AND TO
RECOGNIZE THE SURVIVORS.
TODAY WE GRIEVE FOR ALL VICTIMS
OF THE HOLOCAUST WHICH INCLUDES
NOT ONLY JEWS BUT ALSO ROMA.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES GAY
PEOPLE AND POLITICAL OPPONENTS
OF THE **** REGIME.
AT THE SAME TIME WE MUST
RECOGNIZE THAT THE HOLOCAUST WAS
FIRST AND FOREMOST IN EFFORT TO
DESTROY THE JEWISH PEOPLE. THREE
RACE US FROM HISTORY.
THE HARM ARE ARE THE HALLMARKS
OF THE HOLOCAUST WERE
EXTRAORDINARY EFFICIENCY.
INCREDIBLE BRUTALITY SHOCKING
SILENCE AND PAINFUL COMPLICITY.
IN A FEW SHORT YEARS THE ****
MURDERED SIX MILLION JEWS
INCLUDING ONE MILLION JEWISH
CHILDREN.
AND DECIMATED EUROPEAN JEWRY.
AT EVERY CONCEIVABLE OPPORTUNITY
THE **** SOUGHT TO HUMILIATE AND
DE HUMANIZE TO USE. TO DEPRIVE
THE VICTIMS OF THEIR IDENTITY
AND THEIR DIGNITY AND TO PROVE
THE SUPPOSE IT A RACIAL
INFERIORITY OF THE JEWISH PEOPLE.
IN MANY COMMUNITIES WERE JEWS
HAVE LIVED FOR CENTURIES THEIR
NEIGHBOR STOOD BY SILENTLY.
OR EAGERLY COLLABORATED WITH THE
**** IF THROUGH THE ASTOR KLAY
ASSISTING WITH THE
IDENTIFICATION AND MURDER OF
THEIR JEWISH NEIGHBORS AND
COLLEAGUES.
AND SO TODAY AS WE DO EVERY YEAR
WE PAUSE AND REMEMBER THE
HOLOCAUST.
WE MUST REMEMBER IT BECAUSE THE
TEMPTATION TO IGNORE IT IS
OVERWHELMING.
AFTER ALL IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE TO
THINK ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST. TO
IMAGINE FAMILIES PACKED TIGHTLY
INTO CATTLE CARS OR MOTHERS WITH
INFANTS BEING SHOVED INTO GAS
CHAMBERS. TO EXPLAIN MOBILE
KILLING SQUADS AND DEATH MARCHES
IN MASS STARVATION. TO THINK
ABOUT CHILDREN AND OLD PEOPLE
WHO WERE LOCKED INSIDE
SYNAGOGUES AND BURNED ALIVE. TO
IMAGINE THE SMOKE AND ASHES FROM
THE CREMATORIA.
YET WE MUST OURSELVES
UNCOMFORTABLE BECAUSE THE MEMORY
IS OUR BEST TOOL TO ENSURE THAT
NOTHING LIKE THE HOLOCAUST EVER
HAPPENS AGAIN.
WE MUST ALSO REMEMBER THE
HOLOCAUST BECAUSE IN TOO MANY
PLACES INCLUDING IN OUR OWN
COUNTRY IT IS FADING FROM MEMORY.
RECENT POLLS SUGGEST THAT 50% OF
AMERICANS LACK BASIC KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST.
AND 20% OF MILLENNIALS HAVE
NEVER EVEN HEARD OF IT.
THIS YEAR WE REMEMBER THE
HOLOCAUST AGAINST THE BACKDROP
OF A DRAMATIC SURGE IN ANTI
SEMITIC INCIDENTS IN THE US.
AND AROUND THE GLOBE.
JUST TWO DAYS AGO IN OUR OWN
STATE WE WITNESSED AND YET
ANOTHER ACT OF VIOLENT ANTI
SEMITISM.
A TRAGIC SHOOTING THAT FELL ON
THE SIX MONTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
KILLING OF ELEVEN WORSHIPERS AT
THE TREE OF LIFE SYNAGOGUE IN
PITTSBURGH.
IN BETWEEN THESE DEADLY ATTACKS
THE CALIFORNIA JEWISH COMMUNITY
HAS ENTERED A SERIES OF ANTI
SEMITIC INCIDENTS.
AND BEEN ALARMED BY THE INFUSION
OF ANTI SEMITISM INTO OUR
POLITICAL DISCOURSE.
AS WE REFLECT ON THESE INCIDENTS
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE HOLOCAUST
DIDN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
IT DID NOT BEGIN WITH GAS
CHAMBERS AND DEATH MARCHES.
IT BEGAN WITH WORDS AND DEEDS OF
A MUCH MORE MODEST NATURE.
WITH HATEFUL RHETORIC AND
PERVASIVE RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATORY LAWS.
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC ELECTION
THAT BROUGHT HITLER TO POWER.
WITH PROPAGANDA THEY CONVINCED A
HIGHLY EDUCATED AND ENLIGHTENED
SOCIETY THE NATION OF BEETHOVEN
AND BACH. TO EMBRACE A CAMPAIGN
OF MASS MURDER.
WE MUST REMIND OURSELVES OF THE
TRAJECTORY OF GENOCIDE.
AND RECALL THAT HATE SPEECH AND
SEEMINGLY ISOLATED ACTS OF
VIOLENCE CAN QUICKLY ESCALATE.
AND SO TODAY WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR ACR.
FIFTY FOUR TO DEMONSTRATE THE
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL BACKGROUNDS
WILL STAND TOGETHER TO RECALL
THE HORRORS OF THE HOLOCAUST. TO
TEACHERS UNIVERSAL LESSONS TO
OUR CHILDREN.
AND TO FORCEFULLY AND
UNEQUIVOCALLY CONDEMN ANTI
SEMITISM BIGOTRY AND HATRED OF
ALL FORMS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL.
IS KHAN LONGER W. ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I RISE.
IN SUPPORT OF A C. R. FIFTY FOUR
WHICH RECOGNIZES TODAY AS
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS SOLEMN
OCCASION IS TO APPLY LESSONS
FROM THE PAST TO CURRENT EVENTS.
DURING THE **** REGIME HITLER
SEWED HATE THROUGH HIS
DISCRIMINATORY LANGUAGE.
CREATING PREJUDICE AND
INTOLERANCE AGAINST JEWS AND
OTHER PERSECUTED PEOPLE.
RESULTING IN THE DEATHS OF EIGHT
MILLION MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
MORE THAN THE POPULATIONS OF LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO SAN JOSE AND
SAN FRANCISCO COMBINED.
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY CALLS
ON ALL OF US WHETHER CHRISTIAN
OR MUSLIM.
BLACK OR WHITE.
FROM BERKELEY TO BAKERSFIELD. TO
RECOGNIZE THE EVILS OF RACISM
AND XENOPHOBIA.
AND SERVES AS A REMINDER FOR HOW
EVEN THE MOST ADVANCED SOCIETIES.
CAN DESCEND INTO DARKNESS.
IT IS APPROPRIATE TO MENTION
RECENT EVENTS.
WHILE SPEAKING TO THIS
RESOLUTION.
SHOOTINGS IN POWER AWAY AND
ATTACKS ON MOSQUES IN SUNNYVALE.
SHOULD NEVER BE CONDONED.
OR EVEN ALLOWED.
BUT IF WE ARE GOING TO ADVANCE
AND HE'LL.
WE MUST COME TO RECKONING WITH
OUR HISTORY IN THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT IS ALL?
OFTEN COMES BACK IN STYLE.
BUT YOU CHEN X. AND SHOULDER
PADS ARE NOT THE SAME.
WE ARE LIVING TWENTY NINETEEN
STYLE.
WHAT OUR COUNTRY SO TO OVER ONE
HUNDRED YEARS AGO?
WHEN WE PASSED THE IMMIGRATION
ACT OF?
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR ITS PRIMARY
FOCUS WAS TO PROTECT WHITE
PURITY AND KEEP IMMIGRANTS OUT.
INCLUDING JEWS.
HELLER USED OUR IMMIGRATION ACT.
AS PART OF HIS PLAYBOOK. FOR HIS
RHETORIC AND HIS REGIME.
AND HE STUDIED HOW WE DEALT WITH
INTEGRATION.
AND NOW IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN WE SEE MUSLIMS
AND JEWS SLAUGHTERED IN THEIR
HOUSES OF WORSHIP.
WE SEE AFRICAN AMERICANS EUROPE
PURGED THROUGH OUR SOCIAL
SYSTEMS.
AND WE SEE PEOPLE FROM MEXICO
AND CENTRAL AMERICA DENIED
ASYLUM.
OUR HISTORY.
IS NOT READY.
BUT OUR PRESENCE.
IS BECOMING EQUALLY DARK.
STANDING AGAINST BIGOTRY DOESN'T
NECESSARILY REQUIRE THE SAME
RISKS FACED BY THOSE WHO HATE
JEWS IN THEIR HOMES OR THOSE WHO
PRINTED AND DISTRIBUTED ANSI
ANTI **** PROPAGANDA.
IT DOES REQUIRE US TO LIVE IN A
WAY IN WHICH WE'VE LEARNED FROM
OUR PAST.
BY WORKING TOGETHER TO PRESERVE
FREEDOM FOR ALL FAITHS.
OFFER HAVEN FOR VICTIMS OF
PERSECUTION CONFRONT BIAS HATRED
AND VIOLENCE IN ALL ITS FORMS
AND SPREAD MESSAGES OF LOVE
ACCEPTANCE AND UNDERSTANDING.
BY TAKING A STAND.
IS IT ABOUT PROTECTING A MASTER
RACE.
OR IS IT ABOUT RESPECTING A
DIVERSE DEMOCRACY.
WE MAY DISAGREE ON A LOT OF
THINGS.
IMPORTANT THINGS.
BUT WE SHOULD ALL AGREE.
THAT YOU SHOULD NEVER BE GUNNED
DOWN.
IN YOUR HOUSE OF WORSHIP.
THE TORONTO TEACHES US THE TORAH
TEACHES US.
SAID ECSTATIC [inaudible]
JUSTICE JUSTICE YOU SHALL PURSUE.
FOR THESE REASONS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS URGES
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AC ARE.
FIFTY FOUR GIVE US COME LONGER
DOES.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE.
LATINO CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF ACR.
FIFTY FOUR THROUGHOUT HISTORY
JEWS HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED TO
UNWARRANTED PERSECUTION.
LEADING TO AN ATTEMPTED MASS SIX
EXTERMINATION AND THE WHOLE
CLASS.
WE KNOW FROM OUR OWN EXPERIENCE
THAT WE MUST BUILD COALITIONS
WITH OTHER COMMUNITIES AND
SUPPORT ONE ANOTHER TO FIGHT OUR
WAY OUT OF OPPRESSION.
TODAY AS WE COMMEMORATE THE
UNIMAGINABLE EVIL OF THE WHOLE
CLASS WE ALSORECOGNIZE THOSE
WHO WERE BRAVE ENOUGH. TO DEFY
HITLER'S REGIME AND PROTECT JEWS
AND OTHERS TARGET BY ****.
HIS BIRTH THOUGH BUSCA SIDE OF
THE A A MEXICAN DIPLOMAT.
RESCUE JEWS THROUGH IS ISSUING
VISAS TO MAIN CO.
HE HELP SAVE THE LIVES OF TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF JEWS.
WE REMEMBER AND HONOR HIM AND
ALL THOSE WHO RISKED THEIR LIVES
TO HELP OTHERS DURING THE WHOLE
ACROSS.
WE MUST NOT LET HISTORY REPEAT
ITSELF.
WE LIVE IN A TIME OF NEW LEAVE
VITAL EYES WHITE NATIONALISM.
WHICH MANIFESTED SELVES AS
RACISM SO IN A PHOBIA AND ANTI
ISM SEMITISM.
WHEN WE STAND TOGETHER WE ARE
STRONGER IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
FORCES THE TARGET LATINO AND
JEWISH COMMUNITIES?
AS WE REMEMBER THE VIOLENCE OF
THE WHOLE CLASS WE REAFFIRM OUR
COMMITMENT TO SOLIDARITY WITH
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY.
AND VOWED TO REJECTS ALL FORMS
OF HATRED AND BIGOTRY TO PREVENT
THE PERSECUTION OF ALL PEOPLE IN
THE FUTURE.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON ACR.
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
MEDINA MISTER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND AND MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF ACR -- FIFTY FOUR
WE JUST FINISHED THE THE HOLIDAY
PASSOVER WHICH WITH THE TORAH
INSTRUCTS US TO TELL THAT STORY
TO OUR CHILDREN.
AND THE HAGGADAH IT ACTUALLY
MEANS THE TELLING.
WHICH IS THE BOOK THAT WE READ
AT A PASSOVER SEDER.
AND WHEN WE DO THIS EVERY YEAR
WITH OUR CHILDREN AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
WHAT IS THE CONNECTION.
OF PASSOVER WHEN THE JEWS WERE
SLAVES IN EGYPT WITH TODAY.
AND I THINK ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE
THAT I HAD TO TELL MY CHILDREN
ABOUT.
THIS WEEKEND THE SECOND TIME IN
THE PAST SIX MONTHS BUT I HAD TO
SHARE WITH THEM.
AS I WAS GOING TO SYNAGOGUE WITH
THAN.
THAT JEWS WERE KILLED AND SHOT.
AT SYNAGOGUE.
BUT BUT WE'RE GOING TO BE SAFE.
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE BEST I CAN
PUT INTO IT FOR MY KIDS AND THEY
TRUST ME.
AND WE GO TO SYNAGOGUE
[inaudible]
AND IT'S EXTRAORDINARILY
CHALLENGING.
AS YOU KNOWTO TELL YOUR
CHILDREN SOMETHING TO HOPE FOR
THE BEST FOR THEM [inaudible]
I AND I TO TO HAVE TO LIVE WITH
THE SCORCH OF ANTI SEMITISM.
WHICH IS A LIVE HERE.
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT IS WHY
ON YOM HASHOAH.
WE WE OBSERVE THAT DAY
[inaudible]
EVERY YEAR.
AND WHY I AM GRATEFUL THAT THE
ASSEMBLY OBSERVES THE HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE CEREMONY.
EVERY YEAR.
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THAT BEGAN.
EIGHT DECADES AGO.
IN GERMANY.
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING SO DISTANT.
IT'S NOT FAR AWAY.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT LIVES WITH
US TODAY SAYING THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED THIS WEEKEND.
ANTI SEMITISM WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR US TO MARK THAT
EACH YEAR.
AND TELL PEOPLE AND SO I WANTED
TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE STORIES.
OF SOME OF THE CHILDREN WHO WERE
KILLED DURING THE HOLOCAUST A
PERMISSION IS A PROP MADAM
SPEAKER.
THIS IS GERRY PRONTO.
A DUTCH JEWISH GIRL.
SHE WAS TEN YEARS OLD WHEN SHE
WAS TORN FROM HER PARENTS AND
SENT TO AUSCHWITZ AND MURDERED.
ON THE TWENTY EIGHTH OF JANUARY.
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR THIS IS
CARLA BETTY VAN BARREN.
SHE WAS KILLED WHEN SHE WAS ONLY
THREE YEARS OLD.
SHE ALSO WAS FROM THE
NETHERLANDS SHE WAS KILLED ON
THE SEVENTEENTH OF SEPTEMBER.
NINETEEN FORTY TWO THIS IS
FRANCIS LEVIN.
HE WAS FROM PARIS HE WAS KILLED
ON THE TWENTY FIFTH OF NOVEMBER
NINETEEN FORTY THREE OUTFITS.
THESE ARE JUST THREE OF THE
MILLION CHILDREN THAT WERE TAKEN
FROM THEIR PARENTS AND KILLED.
BECAUSE THEY WERE GUILTY OF
BEING JEWISH.
THIS ARE MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY TALKED ABOUT
HOW PEOPLE DON'T REMEMBER THE
HOLOCAUST OR KNOW WHAT THE
HOLOCAUST IS.
OR CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT OUR
STREETS WAS IT WAS A DEATH CAMP
SET UP.
BY THE **** IN POLAND TO KILL
ALL OF EUROPE'S JURY.
IT'S EIGHTY YEARS SINCE.
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE THERE ARE
FEWER JEWS IN THE WORLD TODAY.
THAN THERE WERE IN.
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE WE HAVE NOT.
RECOVERED FROM HOLOCAUST
[inaudible]
AND SO.
THERE ARE A FEW THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO AND AND MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT THIS
PARTICULARLY FOR YOUNGER
GENERATIONS THAT.
AREN'T GETTING THIS INFORMATION.
AND THE PHOTOS THAT I HAD.
OUTFITS AND YAD VASHEM -- THE
OFFICE MUSEUM IN YAD VASHEM HAVE.
TWITTER ACCOUNTS WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY POST THIS INFORMATION.
AND THERE IS A NEW SERIES COMING
OUT.
ON INSTAGRAM.
AND I I USUALLY TELL CHILDREN.
DON'T PAY ATTENTION TO SOCIAL
MEDIA.
THERE IS AN ACCOUNT.
EVA DOT STORIES ON INSTAGRAM.
HISTORIANS FOUND A DIARY OF A
GIRL WHO DIED IN THE HOLOCAUST
NAMED EVA.
AND ONE OF HER WISHES WRITTEN IN
THAT DIARY WAS TO HAVE A CAMERA.
SHE WANTED TO DOCUMENT WHAT WAS
OCCURRING.
AROUND HER FROM THE LIFE THAT
SHE ENJOYED BEING PART OF THE
MIDDLE CLASS IN EUROPE. TO THE
**** COMING INTO THEIR TOWN.
BEING FORCED INTO A GHETTO.
BEING TAKEN. TO A DEATH CAMP.
AND HISTORIANS FOUND THIS DIARY.
AND THEY DECIDED TO PUT.
A SMART.
IN HER HANDS.
AND ANA INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT THEY
HAVE.
DOCUMENTED THIS GIRL'S LIFE.
AS IF SHE WAS ABLE. TO DOCUMENT
IT ON SOCIAL MEDIA THE WAY SO
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE DOCUMENT THEIR
LIVES ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
AND I ENCOURAGE YOU -- TO CHECK
THIS OUT EVEN DOT STORIES AND TO
SHARE WITH OTHERS SO THAT THEY
TOO CAN LEARN ABOUT THE
HOLOCAUST MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR MARKING THE STATE
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE MISS
WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY IS
MUCH MORE THAN A CEREMONY TO
RECOGNIZE SURVIVORS OF HISTORY'S
MOST TERRIBLE GENOCIDE.
IT'S A TIME TO REMEMBER THE
HORRORS THAT OCCURRED BUT ALSO A
TIME TO DEDICATE OURSELVES TO
ENSURING THAT IT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN.
WE WERE REMINDED OF THIS
IMPORTANCE OF THIS JUST TWO DAYS
AGO IN SAN DIEGO.
WHEN A MAN DRIVEN BY HATE IT
TACK THE TRIAL BUT A OF POWER A
SYNAGOGUE?
ON THE LAST DAY OF PASSOVER.
KILLING ONE WOMAN AND WOUNDING
THREE OTHER WORSHIPERS.
THIS HORRIFIC ACT OF VIOLENCE
SHOWED US THAT HATE AND ANTI
SEMITISM HAVE NOT GONE AWAY IN
THE DECADE SINCE THE HOLOCAUST.
UNFORTUNATELY AS THERE ARE FEWER
FIRST HAND WITNESSES TO THE
HOLOCAUST EACH YEAR.
OUR COLLECTIVE MEMORY OF THESE
EVENTS.
MAY BE FADING.
LAST YEAR A SURVEY SHOWED THAT
31% OF ALL AMERICANS AND 41% OF
MILLENNIALS BELIEVE THE
SUBSTANTIALLY LESS THAN SIX
MILLION JEWS WERE KILLED.
HALF OF MILLENNIALS COULD NOT
NAME A SINGLE CONCENTRATION CAMP.
TODAY WE COMMIT OURSELVES TO NOT
ONLY REMEMBERING THE VICTIMS.
BUT FIGHTING THE HATRED AND ANTI
SEMITISM THAT ALLOW THE
HOLOCAUST TO TAKE PLACE.
WE MUST ROOT OUT HATE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND DO ALL WE CAN TO
PREVENT IT FROM GAINING A
FOOTHOLD.
AND WE MUST TEACH FUTURE
GENERATIONS ABOUT THE HORRORS OF
THE HOLOCAUST TO PREVENT THEM
FROM EVER HAPPENING AGAIN.
THAT IS THE TRUE MEANING OF
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON MISTER
NAZARIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'D LIKE
TO ALSO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
WEST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY -- FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE THAT CONTINUES.
TO BURN THE ETERNAL FLAME IN
MEMORY OF THOSE THAT WE HAVE
LOST.
AS WELL AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
MARIN WHO SO SAYS SIMPLY AND
APTLY.
SHOWN THREE PICTURES OF THE SIX
MILLION.
SO THAT WE DON'T THINK ABOUT IT
IN JUST THE TESTINGS.
IS THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IT DE
HUMANIZES.
WHEN YOU JUST TALK ABOUT ISSUES
IN THE CONTEXT OF NUMBERS?
SO I THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THOSE THREE PICTURES
FORWARD.
MADAM SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR. FIFTY
FOUR TO ESTABLISH CALIFORNIA
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY.
IN THE DARKEST MOMENT OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY HITLER LETTER
GENOCIDE THAT RESULTED IN THE
SENSELESS DEATH OF ELEVEN
MILLION.
INDIVIDUALS [inaudible]
INDIVIDUALS.
WHICH DOES NOT ACCOUNT ALSO FOR
ALL THE POSTTRAUMATIC IMPACTS
AND THE POTENTIAL SUICIDES AND
DEATHS THAT ARE NOT ACCOUNTED.
FOR THIS RESOLUTION ENSURES THAT
OUR FUTURE GENERATIONS WILL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ABOUT
THIS BLIGHT.
IN OUR WORLD HISTORY.
WE NEED TO LEARN THIS HISTORY.
SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THE HOLOCAUST
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
THIS DAY IS ALSO ABOUT
RECOGNISING THE STRENGTH AND
COURAGE NEEDED TO FIGHT AGAINST
INJUSTICE.
JEWISH AMERICAN ORGANIZATIONS
PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE AS
COALITION PARTNERS WITH JAPANESE
AMERICAN ORGANIZATIONS.
IN ADVOCATING FOR REDRESS FOR
JAPANESE AMERICAN INTERNMENT.
THIS WEEKEND'S VIOLENCE SHOOTING
AS A AT A SYNAGOGUE AND POWER
WAY.
IS A TRAGIC AN URGENT REMINDER
THAT WE MUST NOT KEEP SILENT IN
THE FACE OF BIGOTRY AND HATRED.
WE MUST STAND UNITED ACROSS ALL
FAITHS AND BACKGROUNDS AND WORK
TOGETHER BY SPEAKING UP FOR
PEACE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN VOTING I ON
THE RIGHT ON THIS RESOLUTION SO
THAT WE CAN REFLECT ON THE LIES.
LIVES OF THOSE LOST IN WORLD WAR
TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN MISTER
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE LGBT.
Q. CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF ACR.
FIFTY FOUR TODAY WE REMEMBER
THOSE WHOSE LIVES WERE LOST
DURING THE HOLOCAUST IN HONOR
THOSE WHO SURVIVED THIS HEINOUS
ATTEMPTS AT EXTERMINATION.
MANY GROUPS AS YOU MAY KNOW --
WERE PRO TARGET AND PERSECUTED
IN THE HOLOCAUST ALONGSIDE THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY THAT OF COURSE
UNFORTUNATELY INCLUDES OUR LGBT
COMMUNITY.
HITLER SAW THESE INNOCENT PEOPLE
AS A THREAT TO WHAT HE BELIEVED
WAS THE SUPERIOR RACE.
**** TARGETED GAY MEN BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE THAT THEY WERE
QUOTE UNFIT TO DEFEND THE NATION
IN COMBAT.
AND WOULD DIMINISH GERMAN
REPRODUCTIVE POTENTIAL.
EVEN IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS LGBT
Q. INMATES WERE KEPT IN SEPARATE
FACILITIES FOR FEAR THAT
HOMOSEXUALITY WOULD SPREAD TO
OTHER PRISONERS.
WOULD HAVE RAZA WAS ONE SUCH
SURVIVOR.
HE WAS AT BUCK IN WALL.
HE WAS PINK TRIANGLE NUMBER.
SEVENTY NINE FIFTY TWO HE WORE
THAT PAIN TRIANGLE UNTIL HIS
LIBERATION BY U. S. ARMED FORCES
IN.
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE WHEN HE
PASSED AWAY IN TWENTY ELEVEN
BROWSER WAS THE LAST KNOWN
SURVIVOR TO WEAR THE PINK
TRIANGLE.
THE EMBLEM THE HOMOSEXUALS HAD
TO WEAR.
IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
AND WHILE HE MADE IT A POINT
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE TO SHARE HIS
STORY AND THE STORY OF LGBT Q.
VICTIMS OF THE ****.
AND THE SURVIVORS OF ALL THE ALL
THE SURVIVORS OF THE HOLOCAUST.
WE KNOW THAT UNFORTUNATELY
SOMETIMES THESE STORIES ARE
OMITTED FROM HOLOCAUST
LITERATURE.
AND EDUCATION.
THIS EXCLUSION IS OF COURSE THE
NATURAL EVOLUTION OF GLOBAL
HOMOPHOBIA.
BUT AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED IT IS
ALSO PART OF A GREATER ANTI
SEMITIC EFFORT TO RACE THIS DARK
HISTORY PART PART OF OUR HUMAN
HISTORY.
FROM THE HISTORY BOOKS.
WE MUST SPREAD WOULD OFF STORY
AND ALL OF THOSE.
WHO ARE PERSECUTED AND HOLOCAUST
ESPECIALLY THOSE FOLKS WHOSE
NAMES WILL NEVER BE KNOWN?
WHO SPACES AND STORIES WE MAY
NEVER BE ABLE TO TELL?
IT IS IN THAT SPIRIT THAT ARE
LGBT Q. CAUCUS [inaudible]
HAS CHOSEN. TO RECLAIM AND TO
LIFT UP THE PINK TRIANGLE NOT AS
THE SYMBOL OF THE EIGHT OFF
HITLER MEANT TO TO BE.
BUT AS A SYMBOL OF THE
PERSEVERANCE OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD
NOT GO QUIETLY.
AS WEEK KNOWLEDGE THE HOLOCAUST
AT THE TIME IN OUR HISTORY WE
MUST RECOGNIZE OF COURSE THAT
HATE IS STILL ALIVE AND SO VERY
PRESENT IN OUR MODERN DAY
SOCIETY.
AS A MEMBER OF THE SAN DIEGO
LEGISLATIVE DELEGATION.
MANY OF US WERE HORRIFIED AND
ANGERED.
BY THE ACTIONS OF A LONE
INDIVIDUAL THIS PAST SATURDAY IN
OUR HOME COUNTY.
WHOSE SOLE PURPOSE WAS TO KILL
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY WERE JEWISH.
THIS IS A MOMENTOUS BECAUSE ALL
OF US TO PAUSE AND RECOGNIZE
THAT WE'RE NOT TALKING SIMPLY
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED IN
THE PAST BUT SOMETHING THAT WE
MUST BATTLE EVERY SINGLE DAY
WITH EVERYTHING.
THAT WE HAVE LIVES ARE AT STAKE
MEMBERS.
ABOVE ALL TODAY.
THE CALIFORNIA LGBT Q. CAUCUS
STANDS IN SOLIDARITY.
WITH OUR FELLOW CAUCUS IN THE
JEWISH CAUCUS.
AND WE RISE UP WE WILL RISE UP
AND WE'LL FIGHT AGAINST ANYONE
WHO CLAIMS THAT THEIR IDENTITY
IS SUPERIOR.
AND OF COURSE WE WILL BE FOR A
FREE AN EQUITABLE AND SAVE
SOCIETY FOR ALL OF US.
OUR CAUCUS OR DID YOU ALL TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF A. C. R..
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA MISS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF A C. R..
FIFTY FOUR AND LET ME SAY WHAT
AN HONOR IT IS TO HAVE SO MANY
SURVIVORS ON THE FLOOR THIS
TODAY.
IT'S WONDERFUL TO HAVE YOU ALL
HERE THANK YOU.
OF THE MILLIONS THAT PERISHED
DURING THE HOLOCAUST WOMEN WERE
SUBJECTED TO SOME OF THE MOST
INHUMANE TREATMENT.
MOTHERS WERE SEPARATED FROM
THEIR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
MOTHERS WERE OFTEN MARCHED INTO
THE GAS CHAMBERS WITH THEIR
CHILDREN.
I REMEMBER THAT AT THE TIME MOST
OF THE PEOPLE WHO WERE SENT TO
THE CONCENTRATION CAMPS KNEW
FULL WELL THE FATE THAT WAS
GOING TO AWAIT THEM THEY KNEW
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO THEIR
DEATH.
IMAGINE BEING ONE OF THOSE WOMEN
HAVING TO MARCH INTO A GAS
CHAMBER WITH YOUR CHILDREN.
AND THEN TO HAVE TO WATCH THEM
SUCCUMB TO THE GASES BEFORE YOU
TWO MET YOUR DEATH I CAN'T THINK
OF ANYTHING MORE HORRIFYING AS A
MOTHER MYSELF.
JEWISH AND GYPSY WOMEN WERE
OFTEN RAPED AND TORTURED BY NOT
SEASON WERE SUBJECTED.
TO HORRIFIC EXPERIMENTS AND
EXPERIMENTS THAT IF THEY SURVIVE
LET THEM SEVERAL.
AND DISFIGURED.
YESTERDAY MEMBERS OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN MY MYSELF AMONGST THEM.
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF SITTING
DOWN IN A ROUND TABLE WITH A
GROUP OF HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS I
GOT TO MEET A WOMAN NAME RENEE
FIRESTONE WHO WAS TWENTY YEARS
OLD WHEN ALONG WITH HER PARENTS
SHE WAS SENT BY CATTLE CARS TO
AUSCHWITZ.
NOW HER FOURTEEN YEAR OLD SISTER.
WAS ONE OF THOSE WHO WAS
SUBJECTED TO INCREDIBLY CRUEL
AND INHUMANE MEDICAL EXPERIMENTS
AND THEN EXECUTED BY THE ****.
RENEE HERSELF SOMEHOW SURVIVE
MIRACULOUSLY BUT SHE DIDN'T JUST
SURVIVE SHE WENT ON TO BECOME
ONE OF THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
FASHION DESIGNERS OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY.
SHE THRIVED.
AND TO ME ONE OF THE GREAT
LESSONS OF THE HOLOCAUST IS ONE
OF SURVIVAL.
AND OF SUCCESS AFTER SURVIVING.
AND THAT SHOWS THAT EVERYTHING
THAT HITLER DID.
WAS PROVEN TO BE A GREAT FAILURE
A FAILURE FOR HIS NATION THE
FAILURE FOR THOSE WHO FOLLOWED
HIM -- TO THEIR GREAT SHAME HER
FAILURE TO TO GERMANY THAT STILL
LIVES ON BUT THOSE WHO SURVIVED
WERE ABLE TO CONTINUE REBUILD.
EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE SCATTERED
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD AND I THINK
IT'S THAT SURVIVAL THAT SO MANY
OF US DRAW INSPIRATION FROM
TODAY.
NO I WANT TO MENTION TO IS TO DO
ONE THING THAT I THINK IS NOT
OFTEN OBVIOUSTO PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT JEWISH.
AND MY FAMILY WE HAVE SURVIVORS
IN MY FAMILY AND MY
GRANDFATHER'S FAMILY.
OF THE ENTIRE FAMILY TREE WAS
WIPED OUT ONLY A FEW PEOPLE
SURVIVED.
BUT MANY OF US ONLY HAVE JUDAISM
AS THE CORE OF OUR IDENTITY I
ONLY RECENTLY FOUND OUT THAT I
HAVE FAMILY FROM LAFIA.
THOSE ROUTES WERE WIPED AWAY FOR
SO MANY OF US IN THOSE FAMILY
STORIES MY GRANDPARENTS MANY OF
THEIR GENERATION REFUSED TO
SPEAK ABOUT EXPERIENCES THAT
THEY HAD.
WE'RE ONLY LEARNING ABOUT THAT
NOW FROM SURVIVORS WHO ARE
WILLING TO SPEAK AND WHO ARE
WILLING TO COME FORWARD AND GIVE
ORAL HISTORIES AND TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM.
MOST OF MY FAMILY'S HISTORY IS
LOST ITS LUSTER TIME I DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHERE IN THE WORLD
THEY COME FROM.
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO PUT ALL OF
THAT BACK TOGETHER AGAIN AND
WE'LL NEVER KNOW MOST OF THOSE
STORIES.
SO I I PERSONALLY WANT TO THANK
THE SURVIVORS WHO ARE GIVING
THEIR VOICES TO BRING THAT
HISTORY BACK TO LIFE FOR SO MANY
OF US FOR PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF.
WE HAVE THOSE THOSE FRAGMENTS TO
CLING TO SO YOU'RE GIVING US A
GIFT WHEN YOU SHARE OUR HIS
COLLECTIVE HISTORY SO THANK YOU.
AND I DO WANT TO JUST TALK ABOUT
THE ROLE THAT SO MANY WOMEN
PLAYED IN SAVING LIVES IN WORLD
WAR TWO AND THE HOLOCAUST
LIBERATING PRISONERS FIGHTING
FOR THE RESISTANCE.
HIDING THOSE BEHIND IT NOW
VOICING THAT HISTORY.
THEY WERE HER ROGUE WOMEN LIKE
HANNAH XIN US WHO JOINED THE
BRITISH ARMY IN ORDER TO RESCUE
PEOPLE THIRTY SEVEN JEWS
INCLUDING HANNAH IMAGINE BEING A
YOUNG GIRL WITHOUT TRAINING
PARACHUTING.
INTO OCCUPIED AREAS TO FREE
PRISONERS.
HANNAH WAS EVENTUALLY CAPTURED
AND MURDERED BY THE **** OF FATE
THAT I'M SURE THAT SHE KNEW SHE
FACED BUT IT WAS SO IMPORTANT TO
HER TO SAVE OTHER LIVES THAT SHE
SACRIFICED HERSELF.
I HAVE A NEIGHBOR NAMED CHRISTA
MILLER WHO SOME OF YOU HAD THE
HONOR OF MEETING A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO WHEN I BROUGHT HER UP
HERE ON HOLOCAUST DAY.
CHRIS SO HER PARENTS.
WHERE HER FATHER WAS A PROMINENT
SS OFFICER ****?
HER UNCLE CLAUS VON STAUFFENBERG
WAS ONE OF THE ENGINEERS OF THE
FAILED ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT
AGAINST HITLER.
KRISTA AND HER FAMILY NOW HER
PARENTS WERE EXECUTED FOR THEIR
PART IN THE THE ATTEMPT THE
CHRISTIAN HER FAMILY WERE SENT
TO A TRADERS CAMP.
IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS WITH THE
CHILDREN OF OTHER TRADERS OF THE
**** SHE SURVIVED TO TELL HER
STORY AND THE STORY OF HER OF
HER PARENTS.
TODAY WE PAY TRIBUTE TO ALL OF
THOSE HEROES AND THE ROLES THAT
THEY HAD AND ONE OF THE DARKEST
CHAPTERS OF HISTORY.
WE HONOR THEIR SACRIFICE.
THEIR SPIRIT AND THEIR STRENGTH
THEIR PERSEVERANCE AND THEIR
BRAVERY IN THEIR LEADERSHIP.
WE CARRY THE LIGHT WITH US TODAY
WAS TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
EQUALITY JUSTICE AND PEACE.
I URGE ALL OF YOU.
TO VOTE FOR A. C. R. FIFTY FOUR
I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND FOR ALL OF YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN MR
GABRIEL YOU MAY CLOSE ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND I I
JUST FIRST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO ALL MY COLLEAGUES AND AND ON
THE CAUCUSES. FOR FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND FOR YOUR REALLY
BEAUTIFUL WORDS AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW JEWS ARE.
A TINY MINORITY WE MAKE UP LESS
THAN ONE QUARTER OF 1% OF THE
WORLD'S POPULATION AS I'VE
SHARED WITH MANY OF YOU.
THERE ARE MORE LATINOS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE JEWS IN
THE WORLD AND SO IT IS DEEPLY
MEANINGFUL FOR US TO HAVE YOUR
SUPPORT IN YOUR SOLIDARITY ON
THIS RESOLUTION AND DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE
MENTION IN HER BEAUTIFUL REMARKS
A NUMBER OF US WERE FORTUNATE
YESTERDAY -- TO TO SIT DOWN AND
AND MEET WITH SOME SURVIVORS OF
THE HOLOCAUST.
AND I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET A A REALLY SPECIAL WOMAN BY
THE NAME OF A EVEN A FENCE AND
SHE'S AN ARTIST WHO HAS WORKED
WITH GETTING INVOLVED YOUTH IN
LOS ANGELES.
AND SHE'S A CHILD SURVIVOR OF
THE HOLOCAUST AND SHE SHARED
WITH ME HER STORY.
SHE'S A A HUNGARIAN JEW BY BIRTH
AT THE END OF THE WAR IN
DECEMBER OF NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
JANUARY.
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE THE ****
WERE RACING AGAINST THE CLOCK TO
KILL AS MANY JEWS AS THEY COULD
BEFORE THE WAR WAS OVER THE
WRITING WAS ON THE WALL BUT THEY
WERE STILL PUSHING FORWARD WITH
THEIR CAMPAIGN OF EXTERMINATION.
IT'S ON A NUMBEROF OF OF DAYS
THE **** AND THEIR HUNGARIAN
COLLABORATORS -- EXECUTED ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND JEWS BY SHOOTING
THEM AND PUSHING THEM INTO THE
DANUBE RIVER.
AND THE WAY THAT THEY DID THIS
MOST EFFICIENTLY IN ORDER TO
SAVE BULLETS WAS TO TIE THREE
PEOPLE TOGETHER.
THEY WERE T<c.cyan> THREE PEOPLE</c>
TOGETHER AND THEY WHICH SHE ONE
OF THEM AND PUSH THEM INTO THE
RIVER AND THEN THAT PERSONWOULD
TRACK DOWN ALL THREE OF THEM.
AND THEY WERE DROWNED.
SO A ABOUT AS A FOUR AND A HALF
YEAR OLD GIRL FOUND HERSELF ON
THE BANKS OF THE DANUBE TIED TO
HER MOTHER.
AND TIED TO ANOTHER FOUR YEAR
OLD GIRL.
AND WHAT HAPPENED AT THAT MOMENT
IN TIME IS THAT THE HUNGARIAN
MARKSMAN WHO WAS EXECUTING FOLKS
RECOGNIZE THEM AS SOMEONE FROM
THE COMMUNITY THAT THAT HE NOW.
IT'S WE CAME OVER THE MOTHER HE
WHISPERED I KNOW THAT THE WAR'S
ALMOST OVER AND I'M GONNA NEED
SOMEONE TO STAND UP AND TESTIFY
ON MY BEHALF AND AND HELP.
SAVE ME WHEN THE WAR'S OVER SO
IF YOU'RE WILLING TO DO THAT
THEN I I WON'T KILL YOU RIGHT
NOW I'LL SHOOT YOU BUT I'LL
SHOOT NOT TO KILL.
THIS OF COURSE ON THE SPOT AVIS
MOM ACCEPTED THAT DEAL THE
MARKSMEN SHOT HER IN THE ARM
THEY WERE PUSHED INTO THE RIVER.
AND THEY LAY ON THE BANK OF
BANKS OF THE RIVER FOR SEVERAL
HOURS UNTIL THE EXECUTIONS
FINISH THE THE RIVER WAS CHOKED
WITH BODIES.
AND THEN THEY SNUCK AWAY.
AND EVER SURVIVED THE WAR.
HER SHE IS A MIRACLE AND
EVERYONE OF THE SURVIVORS THAT
ARE WITH US TODAY ARE A MIRACLE.
IT'S ON THEIR BEHALF AND
RECOGNITION OF THEM I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON A C. R..
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
DO YOU WANT THE FIRST ROLE TO BE
OPEN FOR COFFERS.
YES PLEASE K. MR GABLES ASKING
THAT THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SEVENTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ON ACR FIFTY FOUR
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS.
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR AYE.
ALL OPPOSED NO.
THIS MAP RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
TODAY IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER TO REFLECT ON THE LESSONS
OF THE HOLOCAUST THAT WE JUST
DISCUSSED.
THIS WEEKEND HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THE POWER BY JEWISH WORSHIPPERS
WERE ATTACKED DURING THEIR
SABBATH CELEBRATION.
A WOMAN DIED WHILE NEARLY TRYING
TO PARTICIPATE IN JEWISH WORSHIP.
IT WAS SIX MONTHS TO THE DAY
SINCE THE ATTACK AT THE TREE OF
LIFE SYNAGOGUE IN PITTSBURGH THE
LAST ELEVEN DEAD THE DEADLIEST
ATTACK ON JEWS IN UNITED STATES
HISTORY -- IS NO MORE IMPORTANT
VOICE IN THIS REFLECTION THEN
THE VOICES OF THOSE WHO SURVIVED
THE HORRORS OF THE HOLOCAUST.
THIS SMALL GROUP IN TOWARD
AGAINST ALL ODDS AND WE'RE THE
ULTIMATE WITNESSES TO HATRED AND
THE HUMAN BRUTALITY THEY CAN
STEM FROM IT.
THEY ARE THE LIVING EMBODIMENT
OF THE TRIUMPH OF THE HUMAN
SPIRIT.
OVER HATRED AND EVIL.
IN AN EFFORT TO ELEVATE THEIR
VOICES THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS AND
THE DEMOCRATIC OFFICE OF
COMMUNICATIONS HAVE PREPARED A
SHORT FILM IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE SHOW A FOUNDATION.
THE LOS ANGELES MUSEUM OF THE
HOLOCAUST AND THE UNITED STATES
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL MUSEUM.
PLEASED THE LIGHTS AND BEGIN THE
VIDEO [inaudible] FOR ANTI
SEMITISM IS ON THE RISE I MEAN I
NEVER KIDDED MYSELF.
THAT ANTI SEMITISM STOPPED THERE
HAS BEEN A MAJOR INCREASE IN
HATE CRIMES TARGETING THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY.
WHETHER IT IS HATE OR DANGEROUS
IGNORANCE.
PARALLELS TO THE PASTOR'S
BREAKING.
ACCORDING TO A SOURCE SAYS THAT
ARE TELLING US AT LEAST FOUR
DEAD NOW I IN THIS SHOOTING
TAKING PLACE IN THIS PLACE OF
WORSHIP THE SUSPECT IN TODAY'S
MASS SHOOTING AT THE TREE OF
LIFE SYNAGOGUE IN PITTSBURGH HAD
AN EXTENSIVE ANTI SEMITIC ANTI
JEWISH DIGITAL FOOTPRINT SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY.
SYNAGOGUE TARGETED BY HATE THE
LAPD IS INVESTING IN THE CASE OF
ANTI SEMITIC VANDALISM EDITORES
ANIS SYNAGOGUE.
ANOTHER LESSON FOR THOSE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO LINED UP
READ COPS IN THE SHAPE OF A
SWASTIKA BEEN POSTED FOR
PICTURES AT A PARTY.
AND DID NOT SEE SELECTS.
EITHER. SIX THIS IS THE FIRST.
A FREE.
FUTURE.
LISTEN SEVENTY FIVE YEARS AFTER
THE HOLOCAUST **** MARCHING
OPENLY AND PROUDLY IN THE
STREETS OF A MAJOR US CITY.
AS WE REFLECT ON CURRENT EVENTS
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
THE HOLOCAUST DIDN'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT MY PARENTS AND A LOT
OF OTHER.
OF THAT GENERATION TRIED TO
IGNORE EIGHT DIGIT -- THIS ISN'T
GOING TO LAST THIS MAN IS CRAZY
IT'S NOT GONNA LAST WELL THEY
WERE WRONG YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE **** WHO ARE
USING PSYCHOLOGY ON AS THEY
LITTLE BY LITTLE THEY DID THAT
TO SEE SO WE WOULDN'T RESIST
THEM.
LITTLE BY LITTLE DISCRIMINATION
AND HATRED GREW.
INTO AN EDUCATED IN MODERN
SOCIETY ULTIMATELY EMBRACE THE
EFFORT TO BE RACE THE JEWISH
PEOPLE.
COULD NOT.
GOING TO A PUBLIC PLACE.
NO RESTAURANTS -- SWIMMING POOLS
NO MOVIES NOTHING YOU WOULDN YOU
YOU WERE NOT ALLOWED IN ANY
PUBLIC PLACE ANYMORE.
AND THE PEOPLE THAT YOU KNEW.
TALK TO ANYMORE.
FRIENDS THAT YOU HAD THEY WOULD
SHUN YOU.
MOST OF THEM.
NOT BECAUSE THEY HATE US ALL OF
THE SUDDEN BUT THEY WERE ALL
AFRAID BECAUSE THAT WAS THAT WAS
THE WAY IT WANTS. TO TALK TO
JUNE YOU'LL BE PUNISHED SO THEY
WROTE THAT ALL THE JEWS HAVE TO
MOVE INTO THIS AREA WITHIN ONE
WEEK -- MILLION YOU KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE A NOR DO WE HAVE TO
OBEY IT SO THE CHILDREN WERE
DYING ON THE STREETS PARENTS
WERE SITTING.
AND CRYING THE VENDING CANCEL
CLASS AND VERY CROWDED.
AND MOTHER SHE WAS CRYING BABIES
PEOPLE DYING IT TO US.
DIDN'T GET ANYTHING TO EAT
ADDRESS VERY SCARY BECAUSE IF HE
DIDN'T KNOW LEVEES ARE GOING.
BUT MY DEBT TO DRUM POINT CAME
TO US.
CAME TO ME.
AND HE SAYS LEVY AND GO.
IT'S NOT SO GOOD.
I DON'T THINK WE'LL SEE EACH
OTHER AFTER THAT ANYMORE.
THE COPS OFFERS TO KNOW MY NAME.
TO REMEMBER THE NUMBER.
WITH ANTI SEMITISM AND GROWING
PRESENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
TODAY WE CANNOT IGNORE THE
LESSONS OF THE PAST THIS TIME.
FOR PEOPLE TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
WORLD IS MADE UP OF MANY MANY
DIFFERENT PEOPLE WITH THAT IS
THE AND IT IS ABOUT TIME FOR
THAT THAT WE LEARNED THAT THE
START. TO LEARN ABOUT EACH OTHER.
BY EDUCATING -- TO UNDERSTAND
THE SAME AS EVERYBODY ELSE WE
MUST STAND UP TOGETHER TO
CONFRONT THE ANTI SEMITISM
HATRED OF ALL FORMS.
AND THE HUMAN THE PEOPLE IS THE
FIRST STEP.
ON INVITING WHILE IT'S LIKE THE
NAZISM.
WE HAVE [inaudible]
TO DO ARSENAL.
AND THAT'S THE PART THAT IS THE
MOST DIFFICULT.
TO PEOPLE TO REALIZE.
IT'S VERY EASY TO DEAL AND I
DON'T HATE.
DON'T EVER HATE EACH OTHER.
ALL.
START BY A BIG.
TRIED TO UNDERSTAND THE CHILDREN.
AND IF YOU CAN NOT LOVE EACH
OTHER AT LEAST RESPECT THE CHAU.
THE MESSAGE THAT YOU HAVE.
BOB THE HOLOCAUST IS A UNIVERSAL
MESSAGE.
ALL THE THINGS GOING THAT ARE
GOING ON IN THE WORLD.
THE HOLOCAUST WAS A BLUEPRINT.
SO MANY THINGS TOTAL GOING ON
TODAY
. TO MARK HOLOCAUST
MEMORIAL DAY THE MEMBERS OF THE
JEWISH LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY HAVE
INVITED TEN SURVIVORS TO JOIN US.
WEEK THE EXTENDED TO THEM THE
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR AND
HONOREES ARE SEATED AT THE
DEATHS OF THE MEMBERS WHO
REPRESENT THEM.
AND YOUR NAME IS READ PLEASE
STAND YOUR SEATS IF YOU ARE ABLE.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE HOLD
YOUR APPLAUSE AFTER ALL OF OUR
GUESTS HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED WE
WILL SALUTE OUR GUESTS THE CLERK
WILL READ.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM IS JOSHUA KAUFMAN A
SURVIVOR.
JOSHUA KAUFMAN SURVIVED
AUSCHWITZ BIRKENAU THE DEATH
MARCH DACHAU IN BOULDER OF
CONSERVATION CAMPS.
HE EMIGRATED TO ISRAEL IN
NINETEEN FORTY NINE AND FOUGHT
IN THE YOM KIPPUR WAR.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE IS REGINA HIRSCH A
SURVIVOR.
REGINA HEARST LIVED IN THE LOAD
SCHEDULE BEFORE BEING DEPORTED
TO AUSCHWITZ AS PART OF THE
FINAL LIQUIDATION.
SHE AND HER TWO SISTERS WERE
TRANSFERRED TO TO REASON SAW
WHERE THEY WERE LIBERATED.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW MOAN.
IS JESSE LEVY MARTIN.
A SURVIVOR.
JESSE LEVY MARTIN SURVIVED WORLD
WAR TWO BY HIDING IN A CATHOLIC
SCHOOL IN FRANCE HER BOOK NEVER
TELL YOUR NAME TELLS A STORY OF
GROWING UP AS A HIDDEN CHILD.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW IS MAX ARE GARCIA.
A SURVIVOR.
MAX ARE GARCIA WENT INTO HIDING
IN AMSTERDAM BUT WAS FOUND AND
ARRESTED BY THE ****.
HE SURVIVED AUSCHWITZ THE DEATH
MARCH THE DEATH TRAIN TO
MAUTHAUSEN CONCENTRATION CAMP
AND MELT CONCENTRATION CAMP.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA.
IS LEAH RADZINER [inaudible]
A SURVIVOR.
WE READ CENTER WAS BORN IN
AMSTERDAM THE NETHERLANDS THE
DAY AFTER KRISTALLNACHT THE
NIGHT OF BROKEN GLASS.
SHE WAS RESCUED BY A CHRISTIAN
FAMILY.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN IS RUTH MAILER
[inaudible]
A SURVIVOR.
RUTH MAILER IS REGINA'S OLDER
SISTER.
OF ELEVEN CHILDREN ONLY HER AND
TWO SISTERS SURVIVED THEY WENT
THROUGH THE LOADS GHETTO OUTWITS
INTO REGIONS DOT TOGETHER.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO.
IS JERRY WISER [inaudible]
A SURVIVOR.
AS AN INFANT IN NINETEEN FORTY
ONE JERRY WAS SMUGGLED OUT OF
THE BROADEST LOVE A GHETTO.
I WENT TO LIVE WITH THE FARMER'S
FAMILY IN THE HILLS OUTSIDE OF
BRATISLAVA.
AFTER THE WAR HIS MOTHER FOUND
HIM AND HE MOVED TO ISRAEL.
UNABLE TO ATTEND TODAY AS A
GUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU.
A SURVIVOR.
TOBA Y. SURVIVE TO GHETTOS AND
SIX CONCENTRATION CAMPS
INCLUDING AUSCHWITZ BIRKENAU AND
SHE HALL.
AT THE WAR'S END RUSSIAN
LIBERATORS PREVENTED **** FROM
SHOOTING HER AND HER FELLOW
PRISONERS.
ALSO UNABLE TO ATTEND TODAY IS
THE GUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
DR OLIVER HAM PERLMUTTER A
SURVIVOR.
DR OTHER HAND PERLMUTTER WAS ON
THE KINDERTRANSPORT OF JEWISH
CHILDREN FROM AUSTRIA TO THE
NETHERLANDS.
THE DUTCH RESISTANCE HAD HIM IN
VARIOUS PLACES AND HE ESCAPED TO
**** SIEGES.
HE WROTE AN AUTOBIOGRAPHY ABOUT
HIS JOURNEY.
AND ALSO UNABLE TO ATTEND TODAY
AS A GUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
GABRIEL AND BERMAN.
PAULA LABEL VICKS A SURVIVOR.
FOLLOW LABEL X. LIVED IN A
POLISH GOTTA BEFORE BEING SENT
TO AUSCHWITZ BIRKENAU SHE WAS
LIBERATED BY THE SOVIETS AND
LIVED IN A DISPLACED PERSONS
CAMP IN GERMANY FOR SIX YEARS.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS.
I WANT TO THANK OUR GUESTS FOR
BEING HERE WITH US TODAY AND
HELPING US REMEMBER THIS
IMPORTANT EVENTS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN AN AUDITORY
SALUTE TO OUR VERY SPECIAL
GUESTS AND THEIR
YOU MAY BE
SEATED
.
MR GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER WE HAVE -- QUITE A FEW
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US TODAY FROM
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT -- WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME SO
INTRODUCED ALL OF THEM AND ASK
THAT YOU -- HOLD YOUR APPLAUSE
TO THE AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO
HAVE WITH US THE CONSUL GENERAL
OF ISRAEL TO THE PACIFIC NORTH
NORTHWEST SHLOMI KAUFMAN.
AND ALSO IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER STEVEN SMITH THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SHOW A
FOUNDATION.
WE ALSO HAVE A LARGE CAN --
CONTINGENT OF CLERGY AND JEWISH
COMMUNITY LEADERS INCLUDING FROM
THE JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE.
THE ISRAELI AMERICAN COUNCIL THE
ASHRAM FAMILY J. C. C. THE LOS
ANGELES MUSEUM OF THE HOLOCAUST.
I THE DOT ISRAEL OF CALIFORNIA.
THE SHALOM INSTITUTE.
CAMPESTRE CREAMER THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HOLOCAUST EDUCATORS
NETWORK THE SACRAMENTO JEWISH
FEDERATION UC BERKELEY HELL OUT.
DANIEL PEARL HIGH SCHOOL THEN
THE ARK THE JEWISH CENTER FOR
JUSTICE.
THE DAVID LOVE ROSTY PROJECT THE
RELIGIOUS ACTION CENTER IN A
LARGE GROUP FROM THE REAL ESTATE
AND CONSTRUCTION DIVISION OF THE
JEWISH FEDERATION OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS
.
ALSO MISTER SPEAKER I THINK IT'S
A APPROPRIATE TO NOTE THAT WE
ARE JOINED TODAY MANY MANY OF
THOSE IN ATTENDANCE ARE.
THE CHILDREN AND THE GRAND
CHILDREN OF HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS
IN THE ULTIMATE SYMBOL OF THE
RESILIENCY AND AND PERSEVERANCE
OF THE JEWISH PEOPLE SO WE'RE
DELIGHTED.
THE ONLY TO HAVE THE SURVIVORS
BUT ALSO THEIR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN WITH US TODAY.
WANTED TO EXTEND AN INVITE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS TO ALL
OF THE MEMBERS WERE HAVING A
RECEPTION.
AT THREE PM AT TWELVE OH ONE
CASE STREET ON THE FIFTEENTH
FLOOR.
AND ALSO WANTED TO INVITE
MEMBERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY. TO VISIT ROOM
ONE FIFTEEN THE USC SHOAH
FOUNDATION HAS SOME OF THEIR
LATEST TECHNOLOGY CALLED
DIMENSIONS IN TESTIMONY.
AND THERE'S ACTUALLY ENTERED
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERACT WITH A
VIRTUAL SURVIVOR NAMED P. HAAS
GOOD OR HE HAS ABOUT THIRTY
HOURS OF TESTIMONY THAT THEY
RECORDED.
YOU CAN GO INTERACT WITH HIM I I
DID EARLIER TODAY IT'S IT'S
QUITE REMARKABLE ASK HIM
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS STORY AND
HIS LIFE AND HEAR HIS STORY IT'S
A VERY POWERFUL THING SO WE
WANTED TO INVITE.
MEMBERS TO JOIN US FOR THAT AS
WELL.
THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT A
FORMER MEMBER OF THIS ASSEMBLY
THE HONORABLE JACKIE GOLDBERG
HAS JOINED US TODAY.
THAT'S WHAT.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A SPECIAL A
GERMAN IN MEMORY FOR HOLOCAUST
MEMORIAL DAY.
MS BAUER QUE HAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF CATHERINE BY OUR CATHERINE
WAS BORN ON MARCH TWENTIETH
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE IN VIENNA
AUSTRIA.
SHE WAS RAISED AROUND BY THE
LOVE OF HER PARENTS AND HER
GRANDMOTHER.
HER FATHER OWNED A HARDWARE
STORE.
HER DOG WAS HER MOST BELOVED
COMPANION.
SHE WAS AN EXCELLENT STUDENT
TOOK DANCE CLASSES AND PLAY
TENNIS IN HER FREE TIME.
IT WAS ON THE TENNIS COURT IT
SHE WOULD MEET HER CHILDHOOD
SWEETHEART HERBERT.
IT WAS A CHARMED LIFE.
INTEL.
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE IN NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE AUSTRIA WAS ANNEXED
INTO **** GERMANY AND CATHERINE
WAS KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL.
AND EXCLUDED FROM ALL THE
ACTIVITIES THAT SHE HAD LOVED.
I'M CRYSTAL KNOCKED HER MOTHER
TOOK HER AND HER FATHER TO THE
THEATER.
SO THEY WOULDN'T BE HOME WHEN
THE **** CAME. FOR THE BOYS AND
MEN.
DESPAIR CATHERINE'S FATHER FROM
TRANSPORT.
ALTHOUGH HER BELOVED HERBERT'S
FATHER WAS TAKEN TO DACHAU.
THEY WERE VIENNESE THROUGH AND
THROUGH.
IT WAS THE ONLY HOME THEY'VE
EVER KNOWN.
BUT HER MOTHER KNEW THEY HAD TO
GET OUT.
IN LATE NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
KATHERINE'S PARENTS CENTER TO
ENGLAND. TO WORK AS A LIVE AND
SO THAT SHE WOULD BE SAVED FROM
THE FATE THAT WAS TO AWAIT SO
MANY OTHERS.
SAID THAT SHE WOULD X. GAPE
JEWISH EXTINCTION.
CATHERINE WOULD LATER SAY THAT
THE HARDEST DAY OF HER LIFE.
WITH THE DAY SHE LEFT BEHIND HER
GRANDMOTHER.
AND HER DOG.
KNOWING SHE WOULD NEVER SEE THEM
AGAIN.
SHE WAS RIGHT HER GRANDMOTHER
WOULD NOT SURVIVE THE HOLOCAUST.
IN THE MONTHS THAT FOLLOWED HER
MOTHER WAS ABLE TO FIND A
SPONSOR IN NEW YORK.
WHO WOULD GIVE THEM ALL A SECOND
CHANCE AT LIFE HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES?
IN NINETEEN FORTY SHE BOARDED A
BOAT BY HERSELF TO NEW YORK
HARBOR.
WITH NOTHING BUT DREAMS OF WHAT
THE SECOND CHAPTER OF HER LIFE
WOULD LOOK LIKE.
SHE LIKE TO BE CALLED THE
SURVIVOR.
NOT A REFUGEE.
IN BROOKLYN SHE STARTED OVER
WORKING AS A HOUSEKEEPER TO PAY
RENT ON THEIR SMALL APARTMENT.
SHE SOON LEARNS THAT HERBERT WHO
HAD FLED SEPARATELY HAD ALSO
MADE IT TO NEW YORK.
SHE FOUND HIM IN PROPOSED
MARRIAGE SAYING THAT IF THEY
FOUND EACH OTHER AND MUST BE MET
TO BE.
IN NINETEEN FORTY TWO THEY WERE
MARRIED AND IN NINETEEN FORTY
FOUR THEY HAVE THEIR FIRST CHILD
ROBERT BAUER.
WHO WOULD LATER BE JOINED BY HIS
SISTER SUSAN?
HERBERT WHO STARTED OUT WORKING
IN THE FACTORY THE MAN WHO
SPONSORS FAMILY WORKED HIS WAY
UP TO REGIONAL SALESMAN AND IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE THEY MOVED
TO DALLAS.
WE'RE CATHARINE WOULD SPEND THE
REST OF HER LIFE.
SHE NEVER FORGOT THAT THIS
COUNTRY GAVE HER A SECOND CHANCE
AT LIFE. ONE OF HER FAVORITE
PHRASES WAS EXCUSE ME AMERICA.
SHE WANTED AMERICA TO KNOW SHE
WAS HERE.
SHE LED SINATRA THE YOUNG AND
THE RESTLESS AND VEGAS.
SHE WAS REALLY GOOD AT INVESTING
SHOPPING AND BRIDGE.
SHE WAS ALSO A CONSUMMATE
VOLUNTEER.
WORKING TO GIVE BACK TO THIS
COUNTRY AND HER COMMUNITY.
SHE WAS PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN.
PRESIDENT OF THE GIRL SCOUTS OF
NORTHEAST TEXAS AND SAT ON THE
BOARDS OF THE UNITED WAY.
THE DALLAS HOLOCAUST MUSEUM THE
TEXAS STATE MENTAL HEALTH
ASSOCIATION AND TEMPLE EMANUEL
IN DALLAS.
SHE WAS THE FOUNDER OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION OF
DALLAS AND LITERACY INSTRUCTION
OF TEXAS. ONE OF HER GREATEST
HONORS WAS BEING SELECTED TO SIT
ON A GRAND JURY IN DALLAS.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY SIX
GRANDCHILDREN AND FOURTEEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN.
SHE LOVED VAL ABOUT THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF HER CHILDREN
AND GRAND CHILDREN.
MANY OF WHOM HAVE FOLLOWED HER
AND GETTING BACK TO THIS COUNTRY
THE GAVE THIS FAMILY A CHANCE TO
SURVIVE AND TO THRIVE.
CATHERINE WAS NEVER ABLE TO
FINISH HIGH SCHOOL BECAUSE SHE
WAS EXPELLED BY THE ****.
BUT HER SON -- TO PHD IN PHYSICS
FROM STANFORD AND BECAME ONE OF
SILICON VALLEY'S FOUNDERS.
AND IN NOVEMBER SHE GOT TO
CELEBRATE HER GRANDDAUGHTER
BECOMING A CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
SHE DIED ON FEBRUARY SEVENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN AT ALMOST NINETY
EIGHT YEARS OLD.
SHE WAS BLESSED WITH WHO LIVES
AND SHE WOULD SAY.
AND A LONG LONG LIFE AT THAT.
I RICE RICHARD MY GRANDMOTHER'S
MEMORY.
BUT I ALSO RISE TO DURING THE
OF THIS.
SIX ARE THE SIX MILLION JEWS.
QUARTER OF A MILLION HOMOSEXUALS
IN MILLIONS OF OTHERS WHO
PERISHED IN THE HOLOCAUST.
WHO NEVER GOT TO HAVE CHILDREN
AND GRAND CHILDREN WHO COULD
RISE TODAY AND INJURED IN THEIR
MEMORY [inaudible]
MY FAMILY. FOR THE FORTUNATE
ONES THEY GOT THAT SECOND CHANCE
AT LIFE.
SEQUEIRA SAID DELIVER HA.
MAY THE MEMORY OF THE RIGHTEOUS
ABIDE FOR A BLESSING.
MS BAR QUE HANNAH BEHALF OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY.
PLEASE ACCEPT OUR SINCEREST
CONDOLENCES ON THE LOSS OF YOUR
GRANDMOTHER.
AT THIS TIME.
I INVITE RABBI WISE. TO RETURN
TO THE RUSSIAN.
AND DELIVER THE MOURNER'S
KADDISH.
PLEASE RISE IF YOU'RE ABLE.
HE'S GOT ALL THE NEEDS KADOSH
SHIMEI RABBI.
BELMONT YOU FROM HERE HEY.
WE ONLY COME OFF -- TODAY.
THE HIGHEST PHONE OF YOUR MATH
ON FRIDAY TO HOLD BATES YOU
START OUT.
LOG A LOT OF THESE MINE CAR
REEVE TEAM RAIL.
AYE MAN.
YEAH HEY SHE MAY ROB BONTA OF
OUR ROCK LET ALONE WELL ALL MAY
ALL MY ACT.
EAT OUR OFFICE USED TOBACCO.
THE PEOPLE ARE BEACH FROM MOM
THE NASA.
BEATS HAD DARBY ALAS BEATS HOW
LONG SHE MADE A COULD A SHAFT.
REFILL.
YEAH HEY SELAMA ROBIN MEAN SHOW
MY ****.
THAT HEIDI MOLLY NEW.
HOLE YOU SIR AL BE MARIO ON THEN --
SESSION ALONE BMO MONTH WHO YEAH
I SESSION ON THEM.
ELENA.
COLEUS RIGHT AL.
VMRO ON MEN MADE THE ONE WHO
MAKE PEACE MAKE PEACE IN HIGH
PLACES.
AND WE ALL STAY TOGETHER ON
MEMBERS AND GUESTS ARE
ENCOURAGED TO VISIT THE INTERACT
WITH A VIRTUAL HOLOCAUST
SURVIVOR EXHIBIT.
IN ROOM ONE FIFTEEN OF THE STATE
CAPITOL UNTIL FIVE PM TODAY.
ADDITIONALLY MEMBERS ARE INVITED
TO ATTEND A RECEPTION THAT
BEGINS AT THREE PM AT TWELVE OH
ONE CASE STREET ON THE FIFTEENTH
FLOOR.
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL THE MEMBERS OF THE
JEWISH LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS WE
EXTEND OUR APPRECIATION TO YOU.
FOR ASSISTING US IN OUR EFFORTS
TO HELP FUTURE GENERATIONS NEVER
FORGET.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY WE
WILL TAKE A BRIEF RECESS TO
ALLOW OUR GUESTS TO DEPART FROM
THE CHAMBER.
MEMBERS PLEASE DO NOT LEAVE THE
CHAMBER WE HAVE OTHER BUSINESS
ON FILE
.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETY NINE AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
I THANK ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
SIXTY FIVE BY SELLING MEMBER
QUIRK AND ACTUALLY THE CATS
.
MR QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS ITEM -- THANK YOU
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS THIS IS A
SAVE THE KITTENS BILL -- AB
FIFTEEN SIX SIXTY FIVE ALLOW
KITTENS TO BE MADE IMMEDIATELY
AVAILABLE FOR ADOPTION TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WAVING THE
THREE DAY HOLD PERIOD.
OF KISS KITTENS CAN BE REMOVED
FROM A SHELTER TO HOME WITH
GREATER CAPACITY. TO MANAGE THE
HIGHER MAINTENANCE NEEDS THEY
HAVE A MUCH GREATER CHANCE OF
POSITIVE OUTCOMES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I'VE ARE.
SYRIAN IN HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRED -- PLEASE
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE EYES FIFTY SIX NO.
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES MOVING
TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX AB
FIFTEEN FORTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL FIFTEEN FORTY ONE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER GRAY AND
ACTUALLY THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
MR GRAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER BUT YOU.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY ONE REQUIRE THE
ABC APPEALS BOARD AND TOWARD
WITHIN NINETY DAYS AFTER THE
FILING OF AN APPEAL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
QUEER QUELLE CLOSER ON TELLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY NO.
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE OH ONE
AB THREE FORTY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER AND
ASHLAND A WORKERS COMPENSATION.
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE FORTY SIX CORRECT IN
EQUITY AN EXISTING LAW WHERE IS
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED.
SCHOOL DISTRICT SCHOOL POLICE
OFFICERS RECEIVED A WORKERS
COMPENSATION BENEFITS UNDER
LABOR CODE SECTION.
FORTY FIFTY ANOTHER SCHOOL
POLICE OFFICERS DO NOT.
COME REFER TO AS FORTY FIFTY
TIME THIS TEMPORARY DISABILITY
BENEFIT PROVIDES POLICE OFFICERS
WITH UP TO A YEAR PAID LEAVE IF
INJURED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN FIVE POINT 2%
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS REPORTED
BEING THREATENED OR BULLIES WITH
A WEAPON ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
DURING THE SAME YEAR TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS REMOVED FROM
CAMPUS FOR THIS ONE DAY AFTER
BEING INVOLVED IN A VIOLENT
INCIDENT.
SCHOOL POLICE OFFICERS MUST
RESTORE LIFE TO PROTECT STUDENTS
THEY SHOULD BE PROVIDED THE SAME
BENEFIT IF INJURED ON THE JOB.
THIS BILLS LIMITED SCOPE EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY TO THIS BENEFIT TO
US AND THREE HUNDRED SCHOOL
POLICE OFFICERS.
THIS BILL IS THE ZERO NO VOTES
ESPECIALLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MR FLOOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS ITEM THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB THREE FORTY SIX OF
THE BILL SUPPORT OUR POLICE
OFFICERS WORKING IN SCHOOLS.
WHO ARE PROTECTING OUR KIDS I
WOULD URGE ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
TO SUPPORT THIS MAJOR TODAY
THANK YOU?
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM MISTER
COOPER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ART ABOUT.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE I SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN
AB FOR SIXTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
A SINGLE FOR SIXTY SEVEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER BURNER FOR A BATH
AND ACTUALLY IN THE USE OF STATE
PROPERTY.
EARNHARDT BACK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SAY
IMPRISONING AB FOR SIXTY SEVEN
TO REQUIRE EQUAL PRIZE PAY FOR
BOTH MEN AND WOMEN ATHLETES WHEN
COMPETING ON STATE PROPERTY.
USE FOR RECREATION THE SPORTS
WORD AT THE WORLD HAS
HISTORICALLY ENGAGE IN THE
PRACTICE OF PAYING WOMEN
MARKEDLY LESS THAN MEN.
ACROSS THE SPORTS SECTORS PAY
DESPAIR IS A DISPARITIES EXIST
ESPECIALLY IN INDEPENDENT
NONTRADITIONAL SPORTS.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA COAST COMMISSION WITH
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
DETERMINED THAT IT WOULD ONLY
LEAST THE PUBLIC BEACH FOR THE
MAVERICKS SURF CONTEST.
IF EQUAL PRIZE COMPENSATION IS
GUARANTEED FOR BOTH THE MEN'S
AND WOMEN'S DIVISION.
AB FOR SIXTY SEVEN WOULD CODIFY
THIS DECISION BY THE CLOSE THE
COMMISSION THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO REQUIRE EQUAL PAY
PRIZE FOR BOTH MEN AND WOMEN
ATHLETES COMPETING ON STATE
PROPERTY.
OUR STATE SCHOOL IS TO PROMOTE
EQUALITY AND EQUITY ACROSS ALL
SECTORS OF SOCIETY THIS BILL
SURE IS THAT REGARDLESS OF YOUR
WORKPLACE.
WOMEN AND WOMEN ARE ENTITLED TO
EQUAL PAY ON OUR STATE LANDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED ABOUT --
MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE IT.
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SEVEN A. B.
TEN THIRTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TEN THIRTY WILL
EMPOWER PATIENTS BY GIVING THEM
MUCH NEEDED INFORMATION.
THIS BILL WAS BROUGHT TO ME BY
CONSTITUENTS WHO IS ONE OF THE
HUNDREDS OF WOMEN THAT WERE
VICTIMIZED BUT DOCTOR GEORGE
TYNDALL AT USC.
GIVEN THE MORE INVASIVE NATURE
OF PAVEL PELVIC EXAMINATIONS A
RECENT HORRIFIC -- IN RECENT
HORRIFIC TALES OF ABUSE DURING
THESE EXAMS IT HAS BECOME
APPARENT.
THAT PATIENTS WHO BENEFIT FROM
ADVANCE INFORMATION ABOUT.
WHAT TO EXPECT DURING AN EXAM AT
PUBLIC EXAM AB TEN THIRTY
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD?
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS GYNECOLOGISTS
DEVELOP AN INFORMATIONAL
PAMPHLETS FOR PATIENTS
UNDERGOING A GYNECOLOGICAL
PELVIC EXAMINATION WITH BASIC
FOR INFORMATION REGARDING HOW
THE PROCEDURE SHOULD BE PROPERLY
PERFORMED.
PRIVACY AND SANITARY
EXPECTATIONS AND BOARD CONTACT
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO REPORT
ANY INSTANCES OF MISCONDUCT.
AB TEN THIRTY REQUIRES THAT THIS
INFORMATIONAL DOCUMENT BE
PROVIDED TO PATIENTS PRIOR TO
THE PELVIC EXAM AB TEN THIRTY
WILL ENSURE THAT FIRST TIME
GYNECOLOGICAL PATIENTS.
RECEIVE THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED IN ORDER TO JUDGE TO
IDENTIFY AND HOPEFULLY PREVENT
INSTANCES OF SEVERE MISCONDUCT.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED HASN'T
RECEIVED A SINGLE NO VOTE AND
I'M REALLY PROUD THAT I'M ABLE
TO CALL.
JOINT AUTHORED THIS BILL WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LAGUNA BEACH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE [inaudible]
SEEING.
IS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR AB TEN THIRTY AT LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM WITH
YOUR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AND I'M PROUD TO BE AT THE JOINT
OFF AUTHOR ON THIS MEASURE.
BY PROVIDING THIS INFORMATION I
TO WOMEN ABOUT WHAT TO EXPECT
DURING A PUBLIC EXAMINATION.
WE ARE GOING TO PROTECT WOMEN WE
ARE GOING TO EMPOWER WOMEN AND
WE'RE GOING TO PREVENT.
THE RISK OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT
AND ABUSE I I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR EITHER THANK YOU.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO DO THERE'D
OF A ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE A
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEMS TO TEN
THROUGH TWO FOURTEEN IS ANY
MEMBER WE WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND CAN
SING COUNTER.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO THE OFFICER NATALIE CROWN A
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE.
TO THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE.
I SEVENTY THREE NO -- ZERO GO
READ THE REST OF THE SECOND GAME
THING CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE THIRTY FIVE HI SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SOME LEGAL
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO AND ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN OH FIVE I SEVENTY THREE
NO ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
STOP.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
AS DISCUSSED EARLIER THERE WILL
BE A HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE
RECEPTION AT TWELVE OH ONE CASE
STREET ON THE FIFTEENTH FLOOR.
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION ATTEND A AT THREE PM
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY APRIL THIRTIETH
CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY MAY FIRST SECOND
SESSION THURSDAY MAY SECOND
FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM.
WE WILL NOW MOVE. TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENT TO
MEMORIES MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR --
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISS COM LONGER TO HAVE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
HERBERT ROSENBERG.
HER LEFT US ON APRIL SECOND.
TWENTY NINETEEN HIS STORY IS ONE
OF LOVE BOUNDLESS ENERGY AND A
COMMITMENT TO HIS COMMUNITY.
HERBERT ROSENBERG WAS BORN ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIRST NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE IN PHILADELPHIA HE
WAS ONE OF THREE BOYS.
HE SERVED HONORABLY IN THE
UNITED STATES AIR FORCE FROM
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE UNTIL.
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE HE MET THE
LOVE OF HIS LIFE DIANNE
ROSENBERG AT THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY CENTER IN WEST LOS
ANGELES HE LATER TOLD A FRIEND.
I SAW HER ACROSS THE ROOM AND I
SAID TO MYSELF I HAVE TO MEET
HER SHE IS THE ONE TURNS OUT SHE
WAS AND HE ASKED HER FOR HER
HAND IN MARRIAGE.
ON BENDED KNEE IN FRONT OF HER
FAMILY.
HERMAN DIANNE CREATED A LIFE IN
CULVER CITY.
IN FACT THEY LIVED IN THE SAME
HOME IN CULVER CITY FOR FORTY
YEARS.
THEY HAD TWO SONS MARK IN ALAN.
HERBS SERVED HIS COMMUNITY WELL
HE WORKED FOR HUGHES AIRCRAFT
UNTIL ITS RETIREMENT HE WAS
PRESIDENT OF THE FRIENDS OF THE
LIBRARY A MEMBER OF THE CULVER
CITY DEMOCRATIC CLUB.
AND WAS ON THE AIRPORT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE FOR NINE YEARS.
HER BEEN DIANNE TRAVELED THE
GLOBE VISITING ISRAEL HONG KONG
NORWAY LONDON THAILAND IN CANADA.
THEIR LAST TRIP WAS A CRUISE TO
NEW ZEALAND.
THEY CELEBRATED THEIR FIFTIETH
WEDDING ANNIVERSARY ON JANUARY
NINTH.
TWENTY SIX TEEN RENEWING THEIR
VOWS OF LOVE AND DEDICATION TO
ONE ANOTHER AT TEMPLE TO CUBA IN
FRONT OF FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
HERB WAS LAID TO REST ON APRIL
SEVENTH AT MOUNT SINAI HOLLYWOOD
HILLS WITH FULL MILITARY HONORS
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE DIANE
AND SON ALAN.
HE WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY HIS
PARENTS HIS BROTHERS HOWARD
DENNIS IN IRVING AND HIS SON
MARK.
MY HEART AND CONDOLENCES GO OUT
TO HIS WIFE DIANE AND HIS SON
ALAN PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOINING
IN THE MEMORY OF HERBERT
ROSENBERG.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUST COME UNDER DOES
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
TO THE DESTINY PRINTED THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED IN RETAINS.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
CALDERON MOVES MISTER GALLAGHER
SECONDS.
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY MAY SECOND AT
NINE AM
.
VOTE CHANGE STEVEN CHOI.
AB FOR SIX TO SEVEN NOT VOTING
TO HI